e
go
wh I was called just community order and
please join me initially with the Pledge
of
Allegiance Pledge ALG to the flag of the
United States of America and to the rep
for it stands one
nation
individual we're missing all
the
oh that's all right no problem you only
missed the pledge no nothing else I was
just about to go look for you
guys all right
hi in the room we were no problem
show Hi how are you good do good good
good all right I'm going to uh open the
excuse me I'm going to open the uh
public hearing on Senate Bill
185 uh and recognize uh Senator
Apprentice the prime sponsor Senator
welcome good morning chair Lyn and
members of house judici
for the record again my name is suus I'm
the state senator from District 5
representing 15 communities large part
of Grafton County Sullivan County and
one in marrat County the beautiful town
of New London so it's it's great to be
here today thank you for taking the time
to talk with me about Senate Bill
185 so I'm introducing this to establish
the study committee um to look at the
various barri barriers to dis discharge
of patients um really to Safe
environments including you know from
acute care facilities and these
environments could be home environments
they could be Continuing Care
environments and we'll get into that a
little bit further and that's why you
have the purpose of a a study committee
before you so this started well over a
year ago and in conversations with the
New Hampshire Hospital Association I
became aware that there's a growing
population of inpatients in hospital
beds and acute care hospital beds that
don't need to be in those beds but are
in them because they don't have any safe
place to be discharged to and so I'd
heard that this was a Statewide issue um
and I talk to the hospitals within my
district which there are three of them
and confirmed that indeed they have
patients who are in beds that other
patients need and could occupy but they
don't have a place for them to go for
various reasons um hence again the study
committee every case is different this
ISS is most impactful um on the adult
that's actually waiting to go to either
go to a safe home location or to another
facility that isolated world that they
are in in that acute care bed starts to
um starts to close in on them and they
actually I've heard um I've heard
numerous stories of of dwindling or
declining because of the atmosphere that
they're in and the closest folks that
they come to at that point are actually
staff become like family members
celebrating birthdays and holidays there
are patients that have been in these
acute care beds for upwards of a 100
plus days or more and I gather from some
folks that are here to testify behind me
you'll hear some of those exact
statistics from their acute care
hospital so in 2022 the New Hampshire
Hospital associ Association did publish
a report on barriers to discharge this
report highlights patients AC across the
state that remain in these acute care
hospital beds when they no longer need
acute inpatient care the patients remain
in the hospital again not because they
need they don't have a need to leave
they need to stay there but because
there's a barrier to discharge they
range from lack of available supports in
the community including within their
home to insufficient long-term care beds
to legal barriers that may exist so
there's not one particular solution and
every case has been different different
that we've talked about in other words
these are again not medically necessary
that they occupy these beds but they
remain there because there's sadly no
place for them to go so in the early
days of this this was a bill that was
retained and we came back to work on it
again um this year uh we gathered
stakeholders from from hospitals
to from hospitals to disability rights
to AARP to um adult protection Services
we brought in people from all all
different um walks that take care of or
their purpose they have some crossover
into this area of you know adult care
and we couldn't come to a consensus
because there were there were different
situations and each situation
required a potentially different
solution and some of them may be legal
in nature um so with that um I was
fortunate enough that senator Carson
stepped forward and tried to assist me
with this and said why don't we move
ourselves into a steady committee mode
and really drill down on you know
considering that we have a report that
gives us what the barriers are but
looking at each of those what are the
real
solutions um that we can bring forward
we can all agree on and that we can act
in inact so most importantly those
patients or those those those
individuals who are sitting in those
hospital beds that don't need to be
there have a place that they can go
their life is not a hospital room they
can emerge back into the community in a
setting that fits them that's most
important the second piece backing that
up is acute care hospital beds can be
fewer far between and we need to make
those free um when we can so that
patients are not waiting in emergency
departments for beds are being
transferred to other facilities and know
by the way there might not be an
ambulance available for that in facility
transfer because our you know our
healthare system is facing all of these
different challenges so with that said
I'll wrap up we and just again I'm
thankful for the opportunity to talk to
you about this we have a good idea of
what the barriers are we can agree on a
solution Senator Carson was wonderful in
collaborating with me on building a
study committee so we could really drill
down and get these stakeholders to a
place where um we can have solutions for
these individuals who will know longer
need to be you know living at um at one
Medical Center Drive potentially in
Lebanon or whatever an address might be
but back in their Community thank you
chair Lin and members of the Community
Committee I'd be happy to take any
questions you might have and if I don't
have an answer and I do have another
bill I have to go introduce and we have
Representatives here from the hospital
Association and St Joseph's hospital and
maybe more thank
you thank you for thank you for taking
my question
I was a nurse for 42 years most of that
in intensive care I understand exactly
what you mean um but um having
personally run into a thing safety is a
huge issue yeah um that's the I tell
people use the safety where they're not
safe coming home you know but do you f
my husband was uh in the hospital and I
tried to get him into an acute care
Medicare was my obstacle did you find in
any of your research that Medicare ended
up being an obstacle we ended up paying
for ourselves out of pocket for him to
go to acute care but then I fought the
insurance company and won after two
years but Medicare was was a a problem
with this and then the other thing that
I found in working for years
was families don't want them to leave
the hospital because once they leave the
hospital somebody's going to be
responsible for that bill
but until they leave the
hospital the bill is ongoing and
nobody's responsible Tech I don't that's
not the right word but nobody's nobody's
paying the bill right then and there so
those were two different things that I
wondered that when you form this
committee hopefully that you will look
at because it's not just no place to go
there are other entities that seem to um
get in the way so so representative PR
thank you for your question and
financial barriers are indeed part of
the discussion I actually heard more
about the Medicaid component of this
than the Medicare component of this so I
will leave that to um some of the
experts that I have um that we're
fortunate enough to have with us but
certainly that that's part of it and if
you can't if if I may if you can't say
if you
don't have say family members or legal
guardians or someone who's responsible
foray paperwork I don't think legal
guardian is the appropriate term for me
to use here and we can't get them
engaged to even enroll them in one of
these programs that's a barrier as well
I mean it is like literally being on an
island for so many of these folks so
services in the Community Financial
barriers they're all intertwined in this
thank
you thank
you good morning it's wonderful to have
you here you should stay um
I don't think anyone will
question the need to resolve a serious
problem my question to you is what makes
you
think that six
legislators are going to be able to
solve this problem
if all of the work with those who are
directly involved has not resulted in a
solution thank you for the question
representative Smith and it is see good
to see you this morning U there's been
time that's laped since we first engaged
stakeholders and tried to develop
Solutions and with that time we've
gained um some some more Advocates and
interest not just in the legislature but
within the communities but at a certain
point I had to put this on you know we
basically held it to the side and after
it started to sit over here those
including again hospitals and Advocates
who were not in the initial discussions
started to come forward um Senators as
well as Representatives started to be
contacted by their local hospitals or
within their districts whatever area
they're covering and they were like why
aren't we moving forward with this how
can we help you
so in response to your question it is my
sincere hope now that this we have put a
light on this and elevated the issue
that we can get better commitments at
the table to solve the problem or folks
will continue to sit where they
are you're welcome thank you
questions yeah thank thanks and and
thanks senator for um taking the
question um I guess my one concern ER
and maybe it's a practical thing I'm I'm
guessing it's a practical thing is the
end date for for this um of November 1st
2024 it seems like a lot to accomplish
in a very short period of time um I
don't know if that's because we're in
our second year of our of our cycle and
that's sort of a practical limitation
but um I was wondering about about
whether or not that would provide enough
time to actually achieve what this sort
of intends to tackle which is very large
it it thank you representative turn for
your question it is very large and it it
is so half of this is the fact that we
are in the second year but I actually
think we need to leave the date and we
need to and I know it sounds aggressive
but the accelerated timeline is where I
think you know now that we have the
light on the issue we have people that
are really willing to engage in this by
keeping this timeline in place there's
nothing better in my experience than a
deadline that has to be
met
report also as a as a practical matter
doesn't having this this committee's
report will come after um or during the
filing window in the in the two bodies
so this um this allows uh the sponsors
of this bill first all encourage them to
be a bipartisan group but doesn't this
also give them just a few extra weeks to
work it up before we can before the next
legislator convenes in January
2025 so thank you represent organ is
your question that our window would be
small between the time my question is it
kind of gives you a little bit more time
before the filing deadline so they don't
have the a bill that's introduced by
this study committee has a looser filing
deadline than just than one that was
just by introduced by one or more
legislators acting on their own is that
right yes
okay thank you Mr chair and thank you
senator for uh presenting this to us
this morning in your previous uh
research or study that you've done were
the County Nursing Home representatives
from the County nursing homes a part of
the discussion and uh and if not perhaps
going forward the County nursing homes
may present a at least a temporary
solution uh at least getting them in on
the dialogue is has that been the case
in the past thank you representative gon
and through the uh Bureau of elderly and
Adult Services as well as a AARP there
were some connections made to County
nursing homes because they definitely
have a stake in this so um they are U
they have been and we would obviously
encourage them to be involved I think um
I think what I know is one of my
experiences been with study committees
is it does give you the flexibility even
though it's built of legisl legislators
you can decide um you know as a make
basically draw consensus on who you want
to talk to and make sure that they are
in the room uh for you know what ever
points in times as well as the entire
Committee hearing committee the entire
time the committee meets so yes on the
counties welcome them back we'll
continue to start with this Core group
and make sure that's appropriately
expanded for involvement thank
you thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question Senator do we have u
a numbers of how serious this problem is
and stacked up patients in the state of
New
Hampshire good to see you representative
state I miss Claremont um so the
hospital Association will be able to
give you the best number but there was a
point where one of the towers at
Dartmouth Hitchcock had 150 patients
that needed this was within the last two
years um that needed placement and had
nowhere to go well thank
you thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I'm going to show
my ignorance on healthc care because uh
you using a term that I don't recognize
they're waiting
for um I don't know what an an acute
care facility is oh a hospital so um a
hospital so you have 26 acute care
facilities in the state hospitals are
considered acute care and some of them
are also designated as critical access
hospitals so I'm talking about Parkland
Medical Center I'm talking about
Dartmouth Hitchcock Dartmouth health I'm
talking talk about the Elliott hospital
all right which now it makes sense that
uh oh followup and U now it makes sense
that representative gon ask about the uh
uh the County nursing homes because
they're obviously not acute care
facilities no they're typically skilled
nursing beds and um they this is this
may be depending on the nature a place
for that particular individual to go all
right thank you very much you're
welcome thank you Mr chair and thank you
senator for taking my question my
question is okay we have the New
Hampshire Hospital Association a and all
these other groups why haven't they
formed a core group and come up with a
solution over the years so
representative thank you for the
question and I am going to have to leave
but what I am going to say they're
waiting for me in HHS what I'm going to
tell you is that we got those folks to
the table and we could not come early on
to a consensus because the problem was
not as well understood as it is now so
and they were all there uh but it just
we couldn't come to a consensus time has
lapsed interest has built acute
hospitals have spoken up um advocates
for families and patients have spoken up
so we're just in a different place now
thank you and and I do hate to cut it
short but they are waiting for me that's
okay and I thank you very much I have
really enjoyed the back and forth thank
you all right next I'm going to call on
representative Hank and Phillips
please good morning morning welcome uh U
representative hacken Phillips from
Grafton 12 which is the towns of hover
and lime and uh Senator Apprentice is
the actual expert on the topic um but I
did want to come today as a co-sponsor
and express my support for the bill as
amended by the senate for three
particular reasons one um you know I
think this is a life and death issue we
should all recognize that every bed that
is not turned over on a timely basis in
a tertiary care system means that
someone who has potentially a
lifethreatening issue cannot be
addressed at that hospital they cannot
receive the care that they need in the
moment and they're pushed further
outside the envelope of the service area
of our state um into other um service
areas to address their needs and that
you know 5 10 minutes difference can be
a huge huge life and death matter so I
just really want to reiterate the
urgency of the issue second is that um
this is really a business viability
issue for our state tertiary Hospital
Systems who are already meeting several
challenges um postco recovery and U
while each U one of these opportunities
to turn a bed bed over is another
viability point in their business model
to to to remain you know in operation um
is such a critical critical issue for
our state um so please do not um
underestimate the economic value of this
study committee and then third is just
to say that um you know this is a public
health issue and um and that for every
you know Granite State Community that
can support a proper tertiary care
system uh you know our communities
Thrive and are healthier so of course of
course this really do matter so please
keep the big picture in mind as you make
your deliberations today and that's it
so I'm happy to take any questions
questions for this
witness seeing none oh representative
trip thank you chair oh thank you for
taking my
question once again I have to show my
ignorance of the Health Care system
because you Ed the term tertiary health
care what exactly does that mean uh so
thank you for the question um I'll try
to do my best Layman uh definition for
you and basically a tertiary care system
is a large hospital system that has
multiple levels of care so not just you
know kind of like walk-in emergency
services but also like proper Surgical
and internal medicine and I the whole
gam of multiple um healthc care points
of service and like topics of medicine
are all practiced Under One Roof more or
less does that help well you you explain
a follow sure uh you explain a lot of
things but you never use the term
tertiary in your
explanation oh a hospital oh it's yeah
it's like a it's a large hospital system
it's a large Hospital yeah so uh for
instance Dartmouth health is considered
a tertiary hospital system because they
offer a wide breadth of services not
just you know internal Med but it could
also be surgical or it could be um
neurological it covers many different
areas of Medical
Practice one more sure so uh so a
secondary health care facility would be
something that uh like
a
local
Healthcare um well I'm not I I don't
want to um oversimplify the matter but I
think earlier there was a mention about
the County nursing home system where
that would not qualify as a tertiary
care system because you know for
instance they don't have an emergency
department they don't operate surgical
cases there so it's it's kind of a step
down um like nursing primarily driven um
operation so that's it's a different
level of care it's a little lower I
would say so um I'm hoping that helps
for the description other questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much thanks next I'm going to call on
Ben Bradley from the hospital
Association please
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is Ben
Bradley I'm the vice president of state
government relations for the New
Hampshire Hospital Association um our
hospitals are dealing with unprecedented
challenges regarding the inability to
safely discharge patients once they're
no longer in need of acute care services
the issue is complex and the reasons are
very greatly um as noted by Senator
Apprentice last year 185 was retained in
the Senate and amended this year to
establish a study committee that will uh
look into the various barriers to
discharge for patients medically cleared
but unable to leave the acute care
hospital bed
of all the bills in the legislature this
session s SP 185 is one of the hospital
association's top priorities I cannot
stress that enough on any given day in
hospitals across New Hampshire there are
dozens of patients and I can uh suggest
that it's well over a hundred patients
today in an impatient bed medically
cleared for discharge but unable to
leave the hospital Hospital these
lengthy non-medically necessary hospital
stays are caused by a number of barriers
to discharge including but not limited
to things like Medicaid Eligibility
determinations securing
guardianship access to long-term care
and other specialty settings something
as simple as
transportation and occasionally
Insurance
denials these barriers impact not only
patients unable to leave the hospital
but also patients whose care may be
delayed due to a lack of an impatient
bed
availability understanding why patients
remain in an acute care hospital bed
longer than medically necessary will
help identify areas where improvements
can be made to reduce the number of
patients affected that's why this bill
is so important we are eager to work
with members of the study committee
along with a large stakeholder group
that this will require to support any
efforts to engage the community
brainstorm legislative and
non-legislative Solutions and advocate
for patients facing these challenging
circumstances I want to thank you for
the opportunity to provide comments
please take this bill seriously and we
ask for your support I know you will
take it seriously um I'm happy to answer
any questions you have we do have a
updated report on barriers to discharge
coming out very soon that I would like
to provide the committee this will
identify the areas in in our hospitals
where barriers exist how much of a
barrier that
is um how many unnecessary days patients
are staying in hospitals um and uh and
other factors as well
um representative Smith you if I may you
had asked about what um we think a
committee like this would do uh what
what makes us think that a committee of
six members of the legislature could
help resolve this issue I think it's
leadership um at a state level uh to
identify those legislative Solutions and
non-legislative solutions that we can
move forward in the next bium
potentially with budget proposals and
other policy
considerations thank
you representative Smith and then
representative testm thank you actually
this is a question for you Mr chair um
why is this bill before this committee
other than for example Health and Human
Services well that's an excellent
question for which I don't have the only
answer I can give is it it came in our
mailbox and I didn't and I did not uh I
did not think to raise an issue about it
but you raise a good point I think it's
probably too late now for us to it is
too late once the hearing has been
scheduled it cannot be you know changed
to another committee but I think that
the questions that um at least one of of
our colleagues asked reflects that very
precisely that this is not an area where
we have built up
expertise and
so I don't think we are the right place
for this and I add to that my continued
concern that I still don't see why when
the principles have not been
able to reach an agreement since it's so
clearly in their own self-interest to
reach agreement why you think six people
in the end of a term meaning that there
is not going to be any legislation
coming forth from this why you think
that that that would solve the problem I
need to be enlightened
thank um so just in response I think
that initially this bill um when it was
proposed in the Senate went to Judiciary
because it focused on
um patient
abandonment and the need for
guardianship um this has changed uh to
some extent to create this study
committee those elements remain because
there are patients who are stuck in
hospitals that have been abandoned by
their family and need to be assigned
guardianship so there are areas where um
we as a Hospital Association our members
feel um the legislature needs to become
famili amiliar with and help to support
legislative Solutions in future years um
that's why we feel it's necessary to
engage a study committee on this issue
representative
testerman your microphone you need oh
microphone I don't see a reason for this
study committee I see a lot of
members interested people who could sit
down and solve this and we seem to be
asked to come in to fulfill some need
that I don't see being presented I just
I don't understand why a study committee
is necessary why the interested people
and parties who are going to be part of
that can't sit down across the table and
sort this out and then finally come to
us and say I need this action I it just
seems
useless um respectively Mr chairman if I
may respond of course um I think uh it
is critical to have legislative
engagement on this issue um we need
legislative
Solutions and this committee will help
to Foster those legislative Solutions or
at least be able to report on their
findings for legislative Solutions in
future that can be referenced in future
legislator legisl
legislatures um I'm going to just give a
couple of
examples one is it's very challenging to
secure a guardian when patients are left
in a hospital and need to secure a
guardian because either their family is
incapable of making determinations for
their care safe care or nobody is
available um we need a a strong process
for uh securing guardianship ship that
will include ensuring there are enough
Guardians in New
Hampshire um which may include
increasing the number of slots that the
state the state allocates for
guardianship under their contracts it
may include expedited guardianship as we
saw during covid-19 when the Circuit
Court designated a um specific Judge for
these determinations so patients could
secure a guardian and decisions could be
made for those paat s to move into a new
an appropriate
facility another is around Medicaid
Eligibility currently the process for
securing Medicaid is very cumbersome
it's an extensive process and if there's
a way that we can move legislative
proposals that help to ensure patients
may be able to move into a new facility
into a more appropriate facility before
actually securing Medicaid Eligibility
then we want to pursue those options as
well but these are all topics that we
feel are Justified bringing to a
legislative committee that needs to
become familiar and provide um some
reports by gathering
stakeholders uh for legislative
Solutions and non-legislative Solutions
in the future because we don't want to
try to propose a legislative solution
when it can be resolved um without
legislation
so respectfully I I I can't share um how
strongly enough we believe this is an
important bill for the legislature all
right representative
testerman I guess it just seems to me
you know the
answers and you and you you come to us
with a bill to say do this you know
rather than talk about doing it just a
bill for each of those two or three that
you came up with and I'm sure you have
more
and because we're getting towards the
end of a term that many people who are
going to be on some committee won't be
here so it just seems to me that you
you're you're you're basically
asking uh committee to do it just P
around with it and then drop it I it
just it worries me if this is so
critical let's do it come up with four
or five so is there I didn't hear a
question there the question really is
why are you this why why are we doing a
study committee when you already know
the answers or at least the potential
answers that put them put the put the
answers
forward thanks for the question
representative testerman I'm going to
just refer to my previous answers all
right other questions uh yes
representative dorenzo and then
representative tur and then
representative Staples okay mine's just
a quick one thank you for taking my
question and thank you Mr chair um when
do you expect the report to be issued
I would hope uh before the sunset of
this Committee in November uh no that's
not a good
answer do you have a report on data now
uh we have data that we're Gathering
from our Hospitals now yes okay
representative ter because I I just want
to I just feel like we would have a
better idea of what we're dealing with
if we saw the numbers and it
situations and thank you if I may uh Mr
chairman that's exactly the point that
we're trying to make which is we're
gathering information we want to provide
that to a legislative study committee
and work with the state and the
legislature to move some of these things
forward so thank you representative tur
yeah actually thanks and and thanks for
taking the question uh that was actually
a good segue to my question which is and
this is from my non-legislative head on
at the moment but um do you have the
ability to sort of identify these uh uh
days um and situations in the
administrative data either in the
hospital discharge data set or the
all-payer you know claims data set so
that it's possible to sort of and and
I'm thinking within the time frame of a
committee like this um examine sort of
the the subsets within the bigger
problem that it sounds like maybe this
report already is is is focused on like
within different payer groups within
different uh facility types and things
like that so that so that it's not just
kind of an aggregate um I guess the real
question is is the data available and is
that something that could be dealt with
by a sub by a committee uh thank you for
the question representative yes we've
done a lot of there's been a lot of
Labor and and intensive work on
Gathering data from our hospitals on uh
the challenges that they're facing with
getting patients to an appropriate level
of care I feel very confident that we
will be a valuable resource to the
efforts of this study committee and I
believe that we can hit the ground
running on day one
without simply doing introductions and a
overview of the committee uh even on
even the first meeting that we have I
think we can get to um some really
strong and comprehensive information
that will help them form the committee
very
quickly representative
Stapleton thank you Mr chair and thank
you for for taking my
question having been
familiar with helping constituents
through the Medicaid application
process and also involved with the
complexities of
guardianship I can appreciate how much
delay could be attributed to those two
factors alone never thought about the
hospital emergency room Stack Up in such
a regard but because they're so back
logged in
DHHS Medicaid and the courts uh handling
guardianship cases there's a great deal
of time and and resources that are
absent to address that if you could
condense those wouldn't it make it
probably would make sense that you could
move these people along a lot quicker um
I recognize that the legislation is a
component of all the tools that you need
and so it's an important piece that
brings it into Focus to the head of the
culture question how could you give me a
rough percentage about how many people
are stacked up on Guardianship and
Medicaid issues in the system within New
Hampshire um from a inpatient acute care
hospital bed setting um our report
should identify that meaning should
identify how many patients are awaiting
a determination from Medicaid for
Medicaid Eligibility before they can
secure it and move to an appropriate
level of care we will be able to
identify that similarly Guardians we
have we know what patients are in need
of a guardian and SEC identifying and
securing those Guardians um is part of
the effort to uh get patients to where
they need to go so yes I feel confident
we can answer those questions yes can
you just give me a rough ballpark kind
of an idea other than Medical
Transportation other factors how much
guardianship Medicaid might represent
very rough percentage figures of all
those people stacked up in our system so
i' I'd say there's over a hundred
patients Statewide and on on daily and
on any given day for each of those
categories I would say there are
dozens dozens of patients that's my best
representative Andrews
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my
question has anybody in the hospital
Association or any other like a or
anybody been to individual legislators
and said we need this bill or we need
this
bill um I think
that's no but it's part of a
comprehensive effort to propose as part
of this study committee representative
Smith
um I'm I'm a little um unsure about how
to proceed but uh the witness who is a
presenting to us the position of the
hospital Association tells us we need
data tells us the way to proceed is to
have this study committee and tells us
the information that we will need for
the study committee which expires in
November member will be available to us
by November so I think that there's a
little disconnect here and I I hope you
don't mind my making that point Mr chair
and I'm making that comment to you not
to the speaker right no I I hear you may
I respond I don't know if I was unclear
in responding to uh representative D
Lorenzo our data is available within the
next we we have historical date we have
a former report on this it was issued in
September we're updating that report
that should be out this
month which should give insight to the
study committee that would be
established this summer and work
diligently to identify important
legislative and non-legislative
solutions for next legislative session
for the for the next legislature to
consider as part of their report um we
have the data it's not coming out in
November uh it it it's a available now
and I'm happy to provide what we have
historically gathered and any updates
that may be forthcoming but it's
misguided to believe that we we don't
have data available now and and we'd
have to wait until November to get that
to the study committee I apologize if I
was mis no
misguiding representative
Manos thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I have two
questions one is I represent at them so
I'm wondering if you could review the
definition of an acute care hospital
because I'm thinking through whether
exitor Hospital would fall under that
they don't have a psychiatric unit
they're a general hospital so I was
wondering about that yes a a acute care
settings are
hospitals all hospitals in New Hampshire
are acute care
settings yep go ahead my second question
is when someone's occupying excuse me
when someone's occupying a bed for
non-medically necessary reasons who's
paying the bill for that who who's
absorbing the costs of that um thank you
for the question representative the
hospital does not get reimbursed
for um any Services provided that aren't
acute in the hospital so that patient
there there's no payment to the hospital
and the hospital absorbs those
costs
other other questions for this witness
thank you very much sir all right uh
Christine cwell
please good morning chairman Lynn and
honorable committee members this is my
first time doing this so I'm a little
nervous I just want to let you guys know
uh my name is Christina Cardwell and the
director of care coordination at St
Joseph hospital and I thank you for the
opportunity to testify in strong support
of s SP 185 we are very appreciative of
the collaborative efforts of Senator
apprentice and Senator Carson in
addressing a critical issue faced not
only by hospitals but most importantly
our
patients hospitals have been tasked with
caring for individuals who have been
abandoned in the emergency room or main
entrance of a hospital by families who
either cannot care for them at home or
unwilling or are unwilling to do so
hospitals are also finding that patients
are admitted for a medical condition
treated and at discharge the family is
either unwilling or unable to care for
the patient at home leaving the
long-term care planning of that patient
now up to the hospital this results in
an extended length of stay for what we
call social barriers currently at St
Joseph Hospital alone there are five
patients in this situation one was
brought in through the emergency room
and abandoned by Family three of the
patients have family who are unable to
care for them at the patients care for
the patients at home you know what Miss
C I don't mean to interrupt you but it
you've given us your written testimony
and I'm not if if you so I guess what
I'm saying is we we can all of us can
and will read this but there is there is
some we have some time pressure because
we're running a little late so if I
don't want to interrupt you but but it
in terms of productivity it's not
particularly productive to just read
what you've already given us sure what
so I'll just um mention the numbers
because I think the numbers are
sure so um currently at St Joe's there
are five patients today who have been
abandoned uh the total number of days in
the hospital for these five patients is
756 days of those 756 days only 66 days
were medically appropriate um so that
690 days that a bed was held up for
patients who were waiting for
guardianship Medicaid and then placement
into another facility
that at St Joseph's our average length
of stay is 4.1 days so if you do the
calculations for that with those five
patients taking up 690 days of bed days
that left 168 medically appropriate
patients from our community that then
could not be admitted to those beds in
that time frame
um so that I had it all planned just to
read the whole
thing I I understand that I think that
that out of everything that I wrote here
I think that's the most important piece
and and I assure you we we will the
members of the committee will read your
your written testimony don't worry about
that but um so thank you questions for
this witness representative Andrew thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question how long has this acute problem
been go been going
on I it's been going on for I would say
it's been getting worse over the years
um I've been a nurse for 18 years and I
would say maybe in the last five we've
started to see the uptake of Abandonment
um or at least in my um experience it's
been in the last five years that I've
seen it um more so since the pandemic
the co pandemic it definitely ticked up
from there something it's been going on
for a couple of years other questions
other questions for this witness
representative Anders thank you Mr chair
okay this has been an ongoing
problem has the hospital done anything
to try to correct it or is just gone on
and now it's getting to be a severe
problem um so hospitals have tried to
figure out creative ways to discharge
patients safely um my background is the
care coordination and it is our
responsibility to get a safe discharge
plan for patients and there's been times
when we have a safe discharge plan for
home but then the family refuses to take
that patient home so we have a safe
discharge plan but the family says no we
can't really control what the family
does um hospitals do or at least our
hospital I would say has a contract with
a Genesis facility that we can
occasionally use if there's a long-term
care bed available where we will pay the
facility to take the patient while
they're waiting for their Medicaid um
application to go
through but the the issue is finding the
bed and get them to agree to that
contract so we we've tried to do things
um I just I feel that now at this point
we need assistance from
legislation you're welcome other
questions for this witness
yes beyond the health of the individual
who is in the system uh in one of your
beds what is the cost to all other
health care payers into the system with
the burden of this
occurring I I don't really understand
the question so is there a cost to all
Health Care users for providing care for
these individuals who are not paying um
I would say no there's not a financial
cost to other um Healthcare payers for
this particular patient sitting in a bed
there was a cost to the hospital uh
that's a loss of at minimum
$1,660 a day that the hospital is not
getting
paid presumably I I think what the what
the legislator was getting at is
presumably the hospital attempts to
recover that in some way in charges to
other patients the rates go up so to
speak I'm not sure if that is actually
the case okay I don't have anything to
do with the billing process in the
hospital all right representative
Horgan yes I experienced situation with
a family member who unfortunately um was
admitted to the ICU of a well I guess I
now know it's called a tertiary care
hospital a major hospital here in New
Hampshire and
they um what we ended up what we ended
up doing was admitting admitting them to
hos to hospice and they didn't they
actually stayed within the same building
but they were being cared for by
different organization you know with
different funding and so forth so that
is just
something um that this one of the is
this one of the U strategies that this
committee would be would be looking into
possibly certain the opposite is kind of
the flip side of other problem so
there's actual bed and a space available
in the facility but there uh they they
they still handed handed the patient off
to a different different organization is
doing different type of care than what
the hospital was doing so I don't know
if I made myself clear is that one of
the things that this committee would
probably be looking at um I don't
necessarily think that they would be
looking at that Medicare does have a
hospice benefit for what we call uh
General inpatient so hospitals have
contracts with hospice agencies um for
those patients who are at end of life
and need to be in a facility where the
Medicare hospice benefit pays for the
patient to be in the hospital and that
agency then comes in to help care for
them okay good thanks I sort of UND said
what happened to us obviously other
things on my mind aside from the
Medicare benefit but thank so so that's
uh that's something that's already
already being done effectively so the
committee probably would have that much
trouble with that particular issue so
thanks cor
L I just wanted to make a statement
that's all is just saying I'm really
surprised that um your able to get
patients into a nursing home um um
because Medicaid usually always makes
sure that you that the um Medicaid has
gone through before a patient is
admitted to a a nursing home so the
critical must uh it must be very very
critical in order to um Al like you say
have this going
on other questions seeing none thank you
very much thank you is there uh is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
Senate Bill
185 right seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on Senate Bill uh
185 um and I'm going to open the hearing
on Senate Bill 507 and I will recognize
the prime sponsor Senator Whitley
Senator welcome thank you Mr chair good
what are we here morning members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Becky Whitley I'm honored to serve New
Hampshire Senate district 15 which
includes the wonderful communities of Bo
conquered Penacook and hopkington it's
good to see many of you today I'm
honored to introduce Senate Bill 507 a
bill to ensure justice prevails in the
Granite State this bill deals with the
post conviction process and it extends
the time to petition a court for a new
trial in certain cases as a refresher
for folks uh not familiar with the post
commission process the post conviction
process is in place to protect both
innocent and guilty individuals from
inherent human error in the criminal
justice system unfortunately there are
still innocent people who are convicted
of crimes and spend years in prison
while the real offender remains free
although it's exceedingly difficult to
overcome a conviction even for an
innocent individual convictions are
being overturned and individuals are
being exonerated with increasing
frequency in postconviction cases an
exoneration may occur when a person
who's been convicted of a crime is
officially cleared based on new evidence
of Innocence this may this can occur
through a pardon based on actual
innocence an acquittal at retrial or a
conviction being vacated and indictment
dismissed the use of DNA testing has
been used to in to include or eliminate
suspects and exonerate those convicted
in serious crimes there have only been
three exonerations uh in New Hampshire
this low number is despite the fact that
DNA testing has been available since the
1980s although we wish this was because
New Hampshire has a justice system that
is perfect data suggests that the more
likely reason for the low number is that
wrongful convictions just aren't being
discovered one bar to discovery of
wrongful convictions is New Hampshire's
existing archaic statute which provides
only 3 years to overturn a conviction
this timeline does not allow for
consideration of changes in forensic
science new investigative leads new
scientific techniques or procedures or
other newly discovered or better
understood evidence we all know that
science is constantly changing and the
courts in New Hampshire must be able to
accommodate this growth I want to point
out that New Hampshire is out of step
with the rest of New England and is
wildly out of step with the rest of New
England and is only one of Six States
with absolute timelines which we can
talk about further I also want to point
out the American Bar Association their
standard on postconviction statute of
limitations states that a quote a
specific time period as a statute of
limitations to Bar postconviction review
of criminal conviction uh convictions is
unsound and that's what New Hampshire
has conviction finality is meaningless
where the conviction is wrongful there
can be little Comfort to victims in
convicting the wrong person I want to
provide an a an example to illustrate
why this bill is so necessary a man
named Gary was convicted of a brutal
assault and murder out of Massachusetts
in
1983 his innocence was not litigated
until 2017 35 years later well after the
statute would have run Gary's
exoneration began with the discovery
that bitar Mark science was not what
forensic UT ologists had believed it to
be at the time of trial because the
massachusett statute accommodates
changes in science and its statutes of
limitation Gary's case was able to be
litigated and Gary was exonerated this
would not have happened in New Hampshire
under our current statute I just want to
note that the Senate Judiciary Committee
spent a great deal of time working the
with the parties um in crafting this
language you'll see that it is slightly
narrowed from the original version of
the bill there are many many folks at
the table that have worked on this bill
and I will say they continue to work on
it um they you know as the version that
you have before you was sort of hashed
out in a room with County attorneys the
Attorney General's office the Innocence
Project folks who actually work in the
field but of course you know as we
continue to think about the issue we
want to get it right so I would say and
the folks behind me can describe it in
Greater detail I think folks are on the
same page that we do need to change this
absolute timeline but we need to get the
language just right so um I I am an
attorney but I do not practice nor have
I ever practiced in this area but there
are many very very talented lawyers
behind me who do practice in this area
so I will defer technical questions to
how this postc conviction process uh
Works to them thank you very much and I
appreciate the committee's consideration
of the bill and I'm happy to take the
questions that I can questions for this
witness representative Wallace thank you
Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question in the uh case you cited in uh
in Massachusetts what was the was the
actual perpetrator caught and prosecuted
or was just the wrongfully convicted
individual I don't know that thank you
for that question but the folks behind
me will know that yeah thank you thank
you for that question other questions
for this witness thank you very much
representative me I have to re lean
around the represent yeah yeah good to
see you Senator you too um just a quick
one on new scientific understanding is
that defined anywhere or does it just
get its common definition yeah and that
that's a very good question and I think
that is the sort of one of the areas of
conversation it is likely just like in
other states that you know and um your
chair knows this well that often times a
statute is written and the courts need
to interpret it and um and we want to
strike that balance in statute by being
clear enough but not being overly
prescriptive so thank you for
identifying that issue other questions
for this witness seeing none thank you
very much thank you very much next I'm
going to call on uh Cynthia maso uh
please good morning I'm
Cy oh thank you good good okay I'm
Cynthia muso I'm a Staff attorney with
the New England Innocence Project um I
have been with the New England Innocence
Project since uh 2019 but before that I
was a public def in New Hampshire uh and
I was a law clerk uh actually was in
Hill South judin when you were there as
well um so I'm sort of in this unique
experience of having been in the
pre-trial and the postconviction world
um and I'm the only attorney in the
entire State that's working full-time on
postconviction uh litigation and the
only person that's working on these uh
innocence cases uh full-time and I say
all this only to say that I'm sort of in
this unique position of having this
understanding about how this stat of
limitations is impacting our ability to
litigate these wrongful conviction cases
in New Hampshire and how these changes
that we're proposing today would not
only help free innocent people but would
also really improve the criminal legal
system as a whole so the current version
of statute of limitations requires
motions to be filed within three years
with the rendition of judgment this is
virtually impossible um to meet in
wrongful conviction cases and 2016 the
National Registry for exonerations
reported that the average exoneration
actually takes 11 years uh which is
almost three times that three-year limit
that's currently being set wrongful
conviction work is very slow for lots of
reasons it's hard to find case documents
in the years after things um are closed
and resolved Witnesses die they move on
and scientific understanding which we
will talk a little bit about has changed
um as an example I've been litig
litigating a case in New Hampshire since
I started in
2019 uh this case is from 1988 um this
was brought to the Court's attention in
2022 and the Attorney General's office
just in 2024 found new evidence in the
case and it's been with the Attorney
General's office for 2
years it's not a fault issue they did
find the box but it took two years to
find it um and we're in this space where
we can't find the evidence for two years
a three-year statute of limitations is
unduly burdensome um and is preventing
viable claims from moving forward the
current statute also doesn't account for
changes in science so as uh Senator
Whitley explained exped there's been
this um Discovery in terms of bitemark
evidence and that's Gary's case and I
will speak specifically to the facts of
Gary's case um but also there's been
other science and scientific
understandings that have changed so
arson science uh pattern matching so all
the handwriting fingerprinting all of
these kinds of things have changed over
time and we can't account for that with
this statute so if arson science at one
point in time we had a we have a case um
named Victor Rosario uh the man was
charged with arson uh uh they alleged
that he had used a Molotov cocktail to
start a fire in a building as it turns
out fire science has now revealed that
the fire was not set purposefully and
was actually set set accidentally it was
a wiring defect in the building
meanwhile Victor Rosario sat in prison
for 25 years for a crime he didn't
commit if we had been in this space with
this statute of limitations in this
state Victor's case would never have
come to light because we still would
have been in the position where we could
address that because of this statute um
a lot of new other things have have come
to into play and and you know we're
aware of that hair comparisons blood
stain pattern all of those sorts of
things um and it's not just this
discredited science but it's these
advances in Sciences um you know we've
talked about DNA and there is a separate
Statute in the state for DNA
exonerations um but DNA uh can be useful
in different ways um and that three-year
limitation can still uh inhibit us there
as as well not only is it true that only
six states have absolute time bars but
32 have no time limits um for these new
trial motions and what we're trying to
do is really as Senator Whitley
highlighted bring New Hampshire in line
with the rest of the country um I want
to address a couple of points and I I
know one of the things that we've been
talking about with the um County
attorneys and the attorney generals is
the concern that this amendment will be
um
like a change to the standard and how
the court will consider what can be
grounds for a new trial what I would
tell the committee is that that standard
is laid out in RSA
5261 we are not changing amending
adjusting trying to adjust that standard
it's spelled out what when a new trial
can be granted and that standard is the
standard and will be the standard and
we're not trying to change that this
bill is only meant to request a change
in when we can petition so we're just
trying to ask the court right now we
can't even ask the court to consider
things we're just trying to ask the
court to look at it whether it will be
granted or not that standard Remains the
Same so that's one specific issue uh I
know that the County attorneys and are
have raised that you know the language
would be uh usable in that way I think
the language as is forecloses that
because it's very specific that this is
regarding the time limit and doesn't
change anything about the standard and
the standard is SP out in 5261 with no
amendments um with respect to Mr cisari
who's Gary that Senator Whitley
mentioned the reality of that case was
that the original suspect in that case
was a man named Michael the police had
written him off because he had told them
that he didn't do it it turns out that
it was his DNA that was uh found on her
and on the uh stuff at the scene he had
already died so he was not prosecuted
however while he was out he committed
additional rapes and murders in the
community um and so that was something
that could have been addressed if we had
known um in terms of the new scientific
understanding um representative Ming
that you had asked about that language
is used in other states um it's used in
regards to a different uh statute so in
Massachusetts that language is used in
terms of granting new Motions like the
substance of new motions so it has been
interpreted but not in the context of
the changing the stat of limitations but
we add that because there's a difference
between these discredited sciences and a
new scientific understanding of an old
science so we know that DNA has changed
so much over the years even in 2002 we
were using what's called rflp testing we
don't use that anymore hardly at all we
now use PCR testing for example but if I
came into court and said I want to argue
DNA testing you would say we had DNA
testing in you know 2003 and I would say
to you we have much more exacting DNA
testing that can collect that can detect
that can uh be used with more paral
profiles with less information than we
could back in the day so it has been
defined in other places not in New
Hampshire hasn't been used here but the
way it's been used in other places is
different than the way we're using it in
New Hampshire the scientific
understanding would still be governed by
dabert which is the Court's test in
terms of determining whether new science
and new scientific theories and
techniques would be acceptable in the
courtroom that would still apply so the
court would still be able to evaluate
that we're not in any way trying to
introduce something that would be
upsetting to that case law or in any way
subvert it or uh get around it um I'm
happy to take any other questions other
questions for this
witness yes representative Manos thank
you uh thank you for taking my question
as I read the the bill it would apply to
both civil and criminal cases is that
correct that's true so actually this
this is one of the things that we've
been having a lot of discussions about
is this statute was originally drafted
to apply only to civil cases and it's
been interpreted through case law to
apply to criminal cases because there is
no separate uh statute of liit Statute
of uh for a new trial for criminal cases
so it's been interpreted to apply to
both so that's that's correct however
the language that we've specifically
written in here is that the motion for
new trial and any criminal conviction so
the bill itself the the law itself does
apply to civil cases but the amendment
that we're making only applies in
criminal cases so I draw your attention
to section two where it says this time
limit shall not apply to a motion for
new trial in any Criminal conviction so
it it actually doesn't apply uh to these
civil cases although the bill the law as
a whole does apply in civil cases but
our Amendment does not other questions
for this witness so I just I guess I
have one is is this three-year
limitation really of of particular
significance given that you have habius
Corpus available so the thing about
habius Corpus is that as the court as
that as you're very well aware judge
that would um that would return uh your
case to the only to the the court where
the body is held so conquered or Berlin
for the most part for us for folks that
are
incarcerated the court of of conviction
which is where a new trial would be
heard is really the proper court for
these cases to be heard in because this
is the court that you know originally
held the case and has all the evidence
and has heard the case in the first
instance so the hope is is that that
Court would be able to correct their own
errors in that instance I think the
other issue is that habius Corpus has
sort of different standards than the
motion for new trial we've always had
these sort of separate um there's sort
of three main ways to get back into
court in New Hampshire following a
conviction there's a habius corpus uh
provision there's the motion for new
trial which is spelled out in 526 and
then there's the DNA statute which is
specific to DNA and allows you to get in
on new DNA testing if you can get that
from the court I think this is a
separate and important um statute
because it is a different standard than
the hab standard and it puts it back in
the court where it was first heard okay
all right other question represent
minutes I just wanted to follow up what
was the rationale excuse me for limiting
um this to criminal convictions I mean
our concern as for because we're the New
England Innocence Project is really
solely based around criminal convictions
that are are wrongfully occurred I I
really couldn't speak to as all loyers
will tell you we really know just our
little field and the things that should
go outside I I couldn't tell you so and
from our perspective the main concern is
Criminal convictions we don't have the
same uh perspective and we don't bring
the same knowledge to the Civil field
other question representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question um if this bill
were to pass could you see almost
everybody in the Department of
Corrections filing a
petition for newly discovered evidence
um I I mean I see this as like I mean
indeterminable increase but I see this
as like really big increase like
everybody could file a petition and and
try to get the courts to get them to
overturn their case like this seems like
a like a mess so uh again we're not
changing the standard so the standard
for granting a new trial Remains the
Same that's RSA
5261 that standard is still in place so
in terms of the Court screening out
these cases they still would be able to
do that through RSA 5261 we're allowing
additional people to apply for uh to ask
the court to hear their cases the
Practical reality is having been a
public defender for a very long time
although there is sort of a common idea
that everybody in prison is innocent
that is actually not the case um and
they actually don't say that very often
most of our cases resolved by plea and
the Practical reality is that um folks
that will be in those positions uh to
ask for new trials those motions would
be immediately uh identifiable as
uncredible and uh the court could screen
them out there would be there is no uh
guaranteed right for Council there is no
additional uh there would be no
additional um cost incurred and the
reality is is that I I don't think
people would take advantage of this I
think that's one of these alarm bells
that people ring anytime we try to give
people additional rights but the
Practical reality is is that we're
keeping out valid and legitimate and
important claims of actual innocence in
the event uh you know if we were if we
were to say this is too big of a
Floodgate is that we're opening we're
closing these doors to very valid and
very problematic innocence claims uh in
order to not Dison inconvenience the
court other question
representative yeses I'm just thinking
just the staff time of having a somebody
in the court screen out all of these
cases that in itself I I think I haven't
like spoken to inmates recently but I
think that any one of them will want to
at least file a petition to overturn
their conviction they still have the
ability to do that within that
three-year time period so if they were
going to do that on that basis they can
always file that within that three-year
time period as it stands now so if it
was the case that they were intending to
file that there should have been some
sort of flood in litigation in those
initial first three years and there just
isn't so the Practical reality is that's
just not born out by the way the numbers
work um at this point in time anyway
representative
katab thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I guess I'd
like to know how many are currently
within that three-year time period
actually filing something because I do
share a similar concern and it's not
clear in this bill if these petitions
would just be reviewed by the court or
if everybody would be granted
potentially a hearing before a judge and
I could see this as a way resp
respectfully for an inmate to say well
i' I'd like to go on a field trip to the
court I mean and I do mean that
respectfully but when you're
incarcerated and you can't get out I
could see somebody being like it would
be nice to get out for a day and go to
the court I can actually get some fresh
air and and and go somewhere for a day
see some other people um and and I again
I do mean that respectfully but I think
when you're incarcerated for a long
period of time especially the people
that potentially are in there with life
in prison and and don't routinely get to
leave so how many do you do you have
numbers about how many who do file
within three years in I don't work for
the court so I don't have those numbers
and I couldn't tell you what I can tell
you is having been uh in contact
regularly with folks that are
incarcerated most folks don't want to
leave the prison and come down to the
jail which is where they would have to
be if they were going to be held
somewhere else and that's really not
something that they're interested in
doing um it's actually very difficult to
leave and come back because of the
trauma of incarceration and then being
reexposed to a community beyond that to
return back into um the prison after
that is actually extremely traumatizing
and most people don't want to do that
other questions for this witness
representative tur thanks and thanks for
taking the question um I guess looking
at the the the language of this it's
basically hinges on newly discovered
evidence and new testing and scientific
understanding is it your sense that
these petitions could be filed
iteratively um in the future in other
words this is not sort of a single
opportunity to to file for a new case
but you know I mean new scientific uh
methods are coming out every day I'm
wondering whether or not this could lead
to to to representative Alexander's case
you know a a lot of retrying and
repetition I think in the event that a
new scientific understanding arises that
shows that you are innocent you should
be able to come back into court and make
that argument so every time new
scientific understanding of a piece of
evidence comes to court and says this is
something that this is evidence that we
should not have taken into the courtroom
in the first instance and this is not
evidence that we should be relying on
because this is not reliable this is not
accurate and this is not scientific the
court should be willing to adjust its
own practices to allow those cases to
come back to court so to the extent that
a new scientific understanding is going
to generate additional petitions down
the line I hope that that's exactly what
happens because that's how the statute
is supposed to function if the concern
is is that there are going to be
frivolous petitions the reality is is
that as I said the standard Remains the
Same and the court Court can still say
this is a frivolous petition based on
nothing this only allows us to ask the
court to hear the petition that was the
case for the three-year statute of
limitations to begin with so we don't
think there would be additional
frivolous petitions filed under this
under this uh motion under this uh
Amendment and if there was going to be
frivolous petitions filed they would
have been filed in those three years
anyway and to the extent that additional
petitions are going to be filed because
there's new science or new understanding
of evidence that was presented in a case
they should be
of course yep uh so just one follow-up
question um I'm wondering you know it
sounds like essentially you know there's
no real standard for what would
constitute new or different so you could
sort of come back almost immediately you
know and claim that there's an an
additional modification to I'm wondering
whether or not something like a time
limit in terms of how soon after one is
turned down you could come back again
would be something that you would think
would be useful I mean I don't because I
think that the reality is is when we
think about DNA testing in 2003 which
was 20 years ago and we think about it
now it's completely different and the
science is completely different so the
Practical reality is saying oh well you
had the ability to do rflp testing and
you didn't take advantage of that and
now I don't want you to be able to do
anything with that for a while I think
is uh like inhibitory and allows people
to continue to sit in prison for
something they didn't do so our main
concern is that we don't want people to
sit in prison for any longer than they
need to be sitting in prison our concern
in this case is freeing people that are
innocent so the Practical reality is
we've we've put nothing in here about
adjusting for errors of law or uh F what
we what we call uh legal innocence so
the legal innocence claims would be
things like they had a warrant but the
warrant didn't have the proper basis so
they shouldn't have been able to get in
my house that's not the same issues that
we addressing by by this amendment we're
addressing factual innocence which is a
completely different and much more
significant
question yes representative D Lorenzo
and then representative grion uh thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question are there any advocacy groups
in the prison that help um convicted
people with working on a claim sort of
like this so that's a great question um
the at this point in time although there
is a group of folks uh that are within
the prison that sort of help each other
um there isn't an advocacy group aware
that I'm aware of other than sort of the
ACLU that can help people and the ACLU
doesn't do factual innocence so we're
the only ones um and we have no unique
access to being able to help folks
unless they apply to us know about us
and reach out to us yes representative
gon thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your for the information you've provided
for us it
uh the question I have is in the
language of this bill it uses the the
word
Avers what is the standard for avering
something uh in a legal context and is
that a uh tight enough standard or high
enough standard that or would this
potentially need to be modified
somewhere so we don't think it needs to
be modified so under under the the
statute as it stands so we used the we
had we had originally drafted using a
different language but after we had
spoken with the County attorneys this
was the Lang anguage that was more
comfortable was a so uh the reason that
is is because I think that's like legal
language that the courts are more
familiar with the reason why we've
included AES here is because this is a
this is a this is what we're doing here
is a this is a petition standard so it's
not a hearing standard right so the
hearing standard is in 5261 the petition
standard is in this this statute 5264
you know the new
bill so all we're asking is that the
pleadings have to allege these specific
things that's why AES is in there it's
not a standard of proof because we're
not at a hearing stage so at a hearing
stage a higher standard or must prove
this Beyond a reasonable doubt this
clear and convincing evidence this
preponderance of evidence doesn't apply
at a pleading standard because we're
only laying out the the rules for a
pleading at this point and that's why
we've used that here other questions for
this witness saying none Thank you very
very much thank you next Paul haverson
please time say attorney oh all right
sure so attorney uh alberon and attorney
Enders attorney Ed to Deep dive into
this swallet
him thank you good morning my name is
Step Anders I'm an assistant County
Attorney at the marac county attorney's
office with me is attorney Halverson
who's the maram County Attorney both of
us have been prosecutors for over 20
years um certainly we agree with the
spirit of the bill and don't want to see
innocent people incarcerated and I think
that goes without saying that all
prosecutors I've ever spoken to everyone
at the AG's office we all agree we don't
want to see innocent people
incarcerated what what strikes me about
this is it's an amendment to RSA
5264 and when you look at chapter 526
it's the the chapter that deals with new
trials one of the things about chapter
526 is it hasn't been amended since
1842 and that's the entire chapter
itself is in the same condition as it
was in
1842 so being a curious person I pulled
the 1842 revised statutes and this was
originally under title 22 which was
titled of reviews in new trials and one
thing that that has changed in some of
the language is the first part in in
1842 did read in all civil actions which
judgment has been rendered in the
court so certainly this only originally
in 1842 dealt with civil
cases um and that makes sense because
even the language
in you know
5264 talks about judgments and we know
that judgment is a civil thing it's it's
not part of the criminal context and we
certainly know it was civil in 1842
because the chapter before this in 1842
was chapter 190 that talked about all
judgments shall be rendered in dollars
and cents so this is language from 1842
that doesn't necessarily fit into our
modern context one of the other issues
how this doesn't fit into necess modern
context is the the circuit courts were
established in New Hampshire I believe
in 1963
so this statute only talks about
petitioning in Superior Court um and
there's case law that says this only
applies to Superior Court not
necessarily Circuit Court
decisions so I initially have some
concerns about amending an 1842 statute
that deals with civil cases in superior
court to allow motions for new trial in
in criminal cases as attorney M pointed
out there is another spot in New
Hampshire statute's RSA 651 D that talks
about postconviction DNA testing um that
doesn't contain a statute of
limitations and it strikes me that if
maybe there's a new scientific
understanding that perhaps instead of
amending um
5264 it may make sense to either expand
the postconviction D testing to include
other scientific methods other than DNA
or write a completely new statute that
talks about new scientific
understandings when I started doing a
little bit of research on this I found
that Texas has what is sort of
colloquially referred to as a junk
science Statute in the Texas code of
criminal procedure it's section
11.73 and that makes it clear that if
there's a new scientific understanding
that that can form the basis for a Hab
um at least in Texas and that may make
sense to to have a statute similar to
that in New
Hampshire I certainly agree that I was
at the table when we initially
discussed um the language here as was
attorney
Halverson and we tried to come up with
language that again limited this to
criminal cases Our concern with civil
cases was at some point I think in civil
cases you want a final judgment we I
know we had talked about like a motion
of quiet title on real estate that if
that you could file a a motion for a new
trial forever after that you could never
never necessarily have a quiet title in
real
estate but what always sort of concerned
me and didn't feel great about this
proposed language is
that while attorney muso is clear that
this only changes the time frame and I
agree changing time frame is a good
thing it almost seems like this changes
the process as well and the reason I say
that is because when I first read it it
struck me that this was changing the
process that if you could file a motion
that avert a new scientific
understanding you'd essentially be
entitled to a new trial and and I agree
with attorney muso that's not what this
says but I initially read it that way
and then when we sent copies of this to
the the Department of Justice um I know
that there were some concerns from
members at the AG's office that they
thought this sort of changed the process
as well and I know attorney lhan who's
the Senate legal counsel had that same
concern or at least I I interpreted that
to be the same concern uh and we set up
a second meeting but we were a little I
think too late to change anything one of
my suggestions would be if the the
legislature were to pass this bill and
amend
5264 what I would suggest is that to
make it clear that we're only dealing
with the statute of limitations and not
the process paragraph one starts out a
new trial shall not be granted unless
the petition is filed within three years
after the rendition of the Judgment
complained of or failure of the suit and
I would respectfully suggest that
perhaps to make it clear that we're only
dealing with the statute of limitations
that paragraph one be changed to begin a
motion for a new trial shall be
filed within 3 years so replace the
language a new trial shall not be
granted unless the petition is with a
motion for a new trial shall be filed
within three years and that language a
motion for a new trial is sort of stolen
from the rules of criminal procedure
specifically rule 43 that talks about uh
the time frame for filing motions to
reconsider uh but I think that would
help make it clearer that this only
deals with the time frame and and not
the process I'm not sure if attorney how
anything to add and I know I'd be happy
to answer questions if anyone had any it
all comes down it all comes down to the
um statute limitations issue I agree
with with attorney endress uh with his
recommended change on line five there um
there was a question earlier I believe
too about using the word Aver uh I
actually was uncomfortable with that
word to begin with but I looked at the
colloquial definition of of it and I
think it fits uh so I have I have less
um con concern about that uh I think
there are also two questions about uh
the number of uh petitions that may be
filed for a new trial and granting a new
trial how many would be granted um I
think that question flows with what
attorney ERS pointed out concerning our
initial uh reading and other people's
readings of um uh the language in
paragra on line five that attorney
Enders is suggesting to change to make
it clear that this agrees uh or
addresses only a statute limitations
issue uh so should you wish to go
forward with this uh that would be my
recommendation two would be to change
that language on line five as attorney
endress mentioned uh other than that I
have nothing to add to attorney
andress's comments and glad to take your
questions representative Smith thank you
Mr chair um I found your historic
research just fascinating and I thank
you for the time that you put into to it
um but now I'm looking at
2024 and I'm looking at existing law I'm
looking at existing practice in the last
80 years um that has US established in
in practice uh
interpretations I look at uh number
one um and realize that and there's a
question and realize that the only
change in number one is to take the
language uh three and turn it to
numerical
three period and then number two which
says this time limit shall not apply to
a motion for a new trial and goes on
from there so my question is I
understand that you said when you first
read it or when the attorney General
first read it or perhaps when we first
read it we thought perhaps it might mean
this but on more careful reading we see
clearly what is meant and therefore with
all due respect why are there any legs
left on your argument since on further
reading you realized what this meant I'm
I'm glad I can convince you that's what
it means and I hope that if I find
myself in front of a judge with an
opposing attorney who's saying No this
clearly says if we Aver newly discovered
evidence we get a trial that I can
convince that judge that that's not what
it means either and that's my concern is
that when you're dealing with the
criminal justice system you're dealing
with people who are making judgment
calls
and I I'd be concerned that a judge May
perhaps misread that
I I don't want to belabor it's getting
late but I do want to ask
you acknowledging that even the members
of the third branch of government are
some of them at least have not been
perfect of course we know that some have
been perfect but others have not been
perfect don't we
assume that these are knowledgeable
trained people who are in a court
proceeding which under our law and our
Traditions have people representing both
sides and those attorneys are
responsible for making sure that the
questions are raised and answered it
says very specifically shall not apply
and then it goes on
so I don't think we can expect any
legisl
to uh require
Perfection um but isn't this specific
language clearly stated so much so that
when you read it more carefully you
realized
it I think it could be
clearer and and I also think and I mean
and that's why I suggest an amendment to
change it from a new trial shall not be
granted to a a motion shall not be filed
because I think that does make make it
clearer um and unfortunately I think
mistakes can be made and that's why we
have a supreme court and that's why we
have app pellet review my concern is
that when we're talking about new
trials you're also often talking about
victims and you're talking about people
who have gone through trial and maybe
had some what they believe to be closure
in their life and then they get a phone
call from the prosecutor's office 8 nine
10 years later saying uh hey this person
who is convicted after a trial is now
seeking a new
trial I think that can be potentially
stressful and I think it would be
important to get it right to begin
with Mr chair I know we're not supposed
to exchange in dialogue and so I won't
and um but please know that I would
certainly have liked to respond to
questions representative
Manos thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
um the house just passed a bill 1432
that sets criminal and civil penalties
for the use of AI and deep fakes that
injure
people and so I'm just um and that bill
originated from this committee um and so
I'm I'm just um struggling with the lack
of of the lack of civil relief because
theoretically somebody could be
convicted for a criminal offense using
Ai and then new scientific understanding
could come forward that would say this
person didn't create the AI and the Deep
fake but it was somebody else but still
there would be civil liability and so
I'm struggling with that so if you could
help me I'd appreciate I'd appreciate
that for me personally again I find
myself a situation similar to attorney
muso and that I'm not a civil attorney
um so I don't know that I can help you
with that same same from my side are
there was there other questions over
here that I see other yes representative
Stapleton thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question going back to
just the previous discussion a moment
ago I'm going to ask the
question while closure and victims
concerns are immensely important do they
Trump the focus needed on establishing
innocence absolutely not without a doubt
not and I think and in my conversations
with other County attorneys and I
contacted I believe all of them on this
issue and um every prosecutor otherwise
that I talked to local prosecutors all
agreed that the steps if someone has an
issue with the science and uh uh
something something about their actual
innocence it ought to be brought be
before court and frankly I think
attorney mosu and I and attorney erson
every other attorney that I know
wouldn't disagree with that so
peripheral considerations of closure and
victim's
concerns um are not a consideration
for um evaluating new possible evidence
that might point to
innocence not a valid claim right yeah
thank you
right Representative kab no I wanted to
ask a question of the chair if I may but
I can wait till okay all right any other
questions for these
Witnesses seeing none thank you very
much thank is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on Senate Bill
507 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on Senate Bill U oh oh oh sure
yes absolutely um I wanted to ask if
it's possible to
have the committee researcher look into
this a bit because as I'm looking at the
statue that they
that the attorneys before us just
pointed out regarding DNA testing it is
quite an extensive list of requirements
that you have to meet to even be allowed
to have a hearing and whatnot and and
proving like why this DNA wasn't
previously available vers this current
bill before
us is like two sentences verse this
entire chapter and so I'm curious in
these other states which do allow
for broader amounts of times to have a
rehearing if their chapters are more
descriptive on all this burden that you
have to prove I'm concerned that the
terminology and what not would just open
up the floodgates for for for lots of
potential petitions um
and I wonder if we could kind of do a
little bit of research to see what other
states are doing
uh sure we can have I mean we can
definitely ask our um our uh committee
researcher to to look into um other
states and I I mean I know you're right
I I had a I had significant involvement
in the DNA Statute in before I when I
was still on the court um in a in a one
case in particular um but yes we can do
that um all right uh any all right uh so
we have no other Witnesses so I'm going
to close the hearing on Senate Bill 507
um and um I guess what I what I would
like to raise now before we get into our
executive session on the other bills is
um with regard to Senate Bill
185 um I guess I would have to say I I
think I completely share uh the ranking
members concerns
that I'm very suspicious that the report
we get from the study committee in
November is going to say we are at
loggerheads and we haven't really
Advanced the uh the ball very much
but
but maybe I'm just being overly negative
and uh uh you know and and Senator uh
Apprentice may have some some a very
good point that maybe the pressure has
built uh that will cause people to come
together so my inclination is that
despite
sharing representative Smith's
reservations we should uh pass 185 and
so I would propose since it's only a
study committee to execute now if
Senator Smith is agreeable to do that
representative Smith is agreeable to do
that I would consider it actually a
[Laughter]
demot the chair will just soon be R of
you have to raise you have to raise
money to run for the Senate and I won't
do that
um I I
won't stand in the way
unless I hear any objection from any of
my Democratic colleagues if you want to
go ahead
now
and I guess I should say if I you know I
I'm sort of I'm sort of thinking that
from the questioning I was sort of
assuming that everybody was going to say
even even though they had reservations
let we should we might as well go ahead
if if if I'm reading that wrong then
maybe we should do something else I've
got
question I I'm wondering if and it stems
from the question that I asked is
is not only can we permit some of these
patients to to take up some temporary
Residence at a County nursing home and
do can we do this through administrative
rules and not the legislative process
where there could be memoranda of
agreement between the H hospital and the
County nursing home if there already I I
I believe I understood there that
there's already a private nursing home a
contract with between a hospital and a
private nursing home if they can do that
why can't there be something between uh
these hospitals and a and a County
nursing home for a temporary residence
until a permanent solution can be fixed
but that doesn't need to be legislative
at least I don't I would I wouldn't
think so so could there not be something
done through rules that would allow them
to do that right I mean I guess my only
you may be entirely you may be entirely
correct but I mean are I suppose I think
the senator Apprentice if she was here
would say and that's something that the
study committee could you know include
in their report but anyway uh
representative alexand ER then
representative lza and then
representative excuse me I hate to be
stuffy about this but if we are going to
be discussing this
bill then I think you have to open up an
executive
session on this well no well I you know
what I guess what I'd say this I because
the hearing was closed so there either
has to be a work session which would
have had to have been declared or an
executive session which you could start
with the agreement of the chair and the
ranking member but just the general
conversation we could have Dan in the
lunchroom but I don't think we could
have here all right so here's I guess my
question is this I'm I was think I was
thinking that everybody was sort of
generally on the same page that we
should just exec this and get it done it
sounds like I was wrong in that and if
that's the case then I would say I my
inclination would be let's not exec this
today let's EXA it some other time I
think you might be on the you might be
on the the right track that we are all
ready to exact what I'm not sure you're
on the right track with is what the
motion is and that's where the
difference is I agree I think I think
we're all probably ready to move but I I
would say I I want to itl it because I
think people can just get together on
their own where the number of people on
that committee isn't a
quorum representative
Perez I would like us to move to
exact Senate Bill
185 today and see if we can come to a
decision on that before we do any
further in
discussion representative Andrew thank
you Mr chair I am totally against this
bill it should be it and I'm going to
tell you why as far as I'm concerned the
new hang on hang on so so wait minute
hang on hang on what based upon what I
have heard we are not executing this
bill today it's clear that there are
disagreements because I'm G change my
mind I think everybody
AG so let me just fine let's take a hang
on let's take let's take a Stuffle what
so first let me let me sort of propose
it what if the if the motion was ought
to pass on this who would vote ought to
pass wait just hang hang on we're going
to take a straw vote on this we're going
to take a straw vote if if if we were to
exec this and the motion was ought to
pass who would vote ought to
pass right and who would vote something
other than ought to
pass okay so that that is enough to say
we're not going to exec this today we'll
have we need to have a a more thorough
discussion on it
uh and and it sounds like I mean it
sounds like for example myself and the
ranking member would have a different
view so that in itself would say that we
shouldn't we shouldn't go forward all
right a rare
occurrence point of order yes I made it
I did make a motion but you made a
motion but we're not in executive
session so I'm so the motion is out of
order oh I got fatted all right all
right so now now now I am going to open
the executive session on the three bills
that we had noticed for 11:00 and I know
we're behind um it's Senate Bill 314
Senate Bill
327 and Senate Bill uh
435 um I see that we have in the in the
audience and I and I know they've been
waiting um for a significant period of
time so I in the interest of not having
them wait any longer I'm going to take
up 435 first um this is the the uh
unitrust bill um you all have an
amendment which I I sent to you last
night and and it's now been been
circulated this morning it's Amendment
1454 um and so I would like to move that
Amendment and ask if there's a second
second seconded by representative
Wallace um and if I
um just making a note
here um if I could just speak to it
briefly I
think so the first motion you're moving
is ought to pass correct is I'm sorry
ought to pass yes I ought to pass on
this amendment um and I and I guess I
would speak to to say as you I suspect
that many of you as you started to read
this your eyes glazed over because it's
very technical um it uh I think we got
some very good testimony at the hearing
about what the what the these um uh what
the bill is intended to do and um what
the Amendments uh to basically to
correct sort of language uh difficulties
in the bill uh I don't really think that
there's much in the way of if anything
in the way of any substance in the
amendment that changes the uh the
substance of the bill um uh as as
Senator delandro indicated in his
testimony and as the witnesses have
indicated this is an important bill I
think for uh
for continuing to have New Hampshire
move forward as a state that has very
well-developed
and uh modern trust law and so I think
it's I think it's important uh and I
guess that's really and I think it's I
think it's it's done right so to speak
in here um
and so I that's really all I have to say
anybody else have any comments on
435 yes have a question um you know you
said just kind of technical changes and
as I declared last time when we
discussed this bill and as I repeat I
don't understand a blessed thing and so
I'm not pretending that I understand
anything substantively but um when you
say in line 14 D after a trust is
converted to a
uni
trust the
provisions of
56 for c107 shall apply and
then and then everything's crossed
out after that
so tell me what happened to
c107
that's well this is changing Part D
right that you're talking about line 16
to 29 on page one right yep
right and I
see I see
106f I mean I anyway it looks like
that's deleting like just out of that
part D out that out of this list this
whole
piece so um so you know what I think and
I'm going to ask Mr PLO if uh if if if
I'm wrong on this but I
think that
the the material that is crossed out in
uh in
section
um starting on line 16 through 29 of on
page
one are because
that the
c1107 governs that governs that Mr Perlo
I know see you're in the back of the
room if I'm wrong on that please uh you
know correct us and where is part of the
that's page
two uh starting at line 18 I see okay
okay that answers that question thank
you and that was part of the initial
initial bill that didn't change in this
amendment these cross okay are there are
there other um are there other
questions all right so then I you know
what I guess on the amendment can we uh
anybody object if we do that by a show
of hands all right so all in favor of
the motion to uh uh pass the adopt the
amendment please raise your
hand any opposed all right so it's
unanimous
um all right and then
uh and then and then on the uh on the
bill
itself um I would move ought to pass as
amended is there a
second
all right seconded by representative
Wallace all right um and I would ask
anybody anybody have any other comments
questions anything on the bill Mr chair
wh yes representative Doren thank you Mr
chair you know I feel like I don't know
enough about this um even though I've
read everything and I've been through it
and trying to reason you know what this
is all about and what the um liabilities
might be for the state and when I think
of that way I think about the frm
Scandal um from a few years ago where we
ended up um having the taxpayers um put
the bill for the losses because of um
Bad actors and so that makes me a little
bit skeptical so I'm hesitating thank
you okay all right other uh
representative Smith did you have a
comment I I do have a comment
Mr chair and because um I vote first
when we get to um my part of the RO our
part of the Roll Call I want to explain
that I at the moment I am leaning to
oppose or to pass having nothing to do
with the merits but having to do with
the process I have great respect for the
private bar I have great respect for how
they they help
us understand what's happening out in
the real world rather than in Allison
Wonderland where we live here but I
don't have confidence that I understand
the
implications enough to be responsibly V
in a way that might affect the Financial
Security of people in the state I do I
make no pretense that I know what I'm
doing and I make and I don't expect
anyone to
follow um and I might be the only one
who would vote that way I just don't
feel comfortable without our having had
um a subcommittee a work group uh a side
by side and analysis um uh whatever and
so I I want to say that so that no one
thinks that by my
voting any way that I would expect
anyone else to follow thank you Mr chair
all right anyone else representative
Wallace thank you Mr chairman um if I
might just make a couple of comments so
people might understand this a little
bit better um and again this will be the
rers do just sweet and condensed version
as a trustee sitting on um whatever the
type of trust that might be you are
bound by your fiduciary responsibilities
and obligations to both the current
income beneficiaries as well as the
subsequent Airs of the granters of a
trust this change in statute
provides um an opportunity or so that
the trustees can manage both fiduciary
interests to the current income
recipients of the trust income and
future Generations by adopting a hybrid
investment strategy which will ensure
better and Optimal Performance for all
ears and all beneficiaries um going
forward in throughout time and experts
in the room feel free to correct me if
that was not quite
accurate we're getting a unanimous nods
okay so hopefully that might dispel some
of your concerns so I'm sorry do other
people have any comments so here here's
what I I I guess what my concern is this
I if people are uncomfortable voting on
this now I don't want to in any way you
know we we don't have to exec this today
and I'm not and I'm perfectly willing to
put it off my only concern is this I
don't I certainly don't profess to be an
expert in this area of the law and
although we have other attorneys on the
committee I'm not sure that any of us
are experts in this area of the law I
think we did receive testimony from
people who are experts in this area and
I
didn't I don't recall hearing anybody on
the committee questioning them or
suggesting that there was something more
that they needed to hear or that we had
some concerns about things and so I I
guess what I what I'm concerned about is
if we don't exec this today what you
know we our hearing is over so unless we
were going to have another hearing we're
presumably not going to hear any new
Witnesses um and so I'm I'm you know I'm
I'm sort of left with the idea that if
if if we wait two weeks to exec this
we're going to be in exactly the same
position we are in right now um without
any without any further
information um unless you know there's
somebody on the committee that wants to
become an expert in trust law between
now and two weeks and I can tell you
that that's not going to be me um uh but
but um so that that's why I guess I
would suggest that it makes and I would
you know and I would note um this this
has gone through the Senate it's go it's
been gone
through line by line and I think with
great care by uh Mr Perlo and and people
who were working with him who was who
was our one of our Witnesses last time
um when we got the first draft of of an
amendment back um I uh I submitted it to
him to said you know make sure can you
please take a look at this and make sure
that they've Incorporated all the
proposed changes and he and his people
that are working with him went through
it line by line and got back to me with
a very nice sort of summary of here you
know here are things that they missed
here are the changes that should be made
that was submitted back to OS for for
this current Amendment and when the
current Amendment came back I went
through it I I
uh to make sure that the all the changes
that had been suggested were captured
so again I'm you know if people are
uncomfortable in voting on the bill as
on the ought to pass as amended now I'm
then we will not have a vote today I
don't want anybody to leave here
thinking that we there was some Rush
that we had to do this today um uh but
I'm I really am sort of left like where
you know what are we going to do if we
don't do that so can I just ask sort
kind of before we actually take the vote
can I just ask for sort of a show of
hands of who would be willing to vote or
to pass as amended now right
now and who would be who would rather
not do that right
now I'm not asking for a delay okay I'm
I'm not asking for a delay okay I'm just
explaining my vote your vote all right
okay all right so it appears that we
have a fairly substantial majority that
are willing to go forward so I'm going
to ask the clerk then to uh call the
role on my motion seconded by
representative Wallace to ought to pass
as amended on Senate Bill
435 Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep
Andrews rep testerman yes rep Stapleton
yes rep
trip yes rep gon yes cler kab votes yes
rep Perez yes yes rep
Smith no rep Horgan no rep D Lorenzo no
rep Kenny yes rep
Carrie yes rep Mark uh rep Jack yes rep
lonza no rep
Manos yes rep tur yes rep Ming yes
chairman Lynn yes
motion passes 15
to5
okay okay all right um I will write the
majority report um is will there be a
Minority
Report being none
okay all right Mr chair I just request
that the majority report be less legal
ease and something that something that
non- lawyers can understand count on it
maybe like not a full page thank you
short and sweet absolutely no Minority
Report uh no Minority Report um
uh right um all
right no minority all
right okay
all right um next I would turn to
uh uh Senate bille uh 314 relative to uh
competency
evaluations um do I have uh a motion on
that I'll move on to pass right
um representative cutab moves ought to
pass is there a second
I second it all right hang
on representative
trip all right um representative kab
would you wish to speak to your
motion that's okay
right any anybody else wish to speak to
it I you know the only the only other
information I should give you which I um
is I did uh send a copy I just send an
email with a copy of uh or I'm not sure
if I sent a copy of the bill but I sent
an email to the Attorney General's
office asking them if you know do you
have any problem with this uh with this
proposal um uh that kind of thing and if
you do get back to me and I haven't
heard back from them so I assume that
they do not um which gives me comfort
that you know it's not this isn't like
way out in the out in the left field so
um representative uh Smith thank you
um I I acknowledge the problem that is
the importance of the problem that is
addressed here and I owledge the
substance of the testimony that we
receive I am troubled by a a Reliance on
electronic um hearings um particularly
involving by
definition uh individuals who might not
be able to
function at the extremely high level
that all of us sitting around this table
can function um and uh
uh
that bothers me
um and I would
be interested in knowing how other
people feel about
that representative I was concerned
about that as well but then I I remember
seeing in the bill that it stated that
you only had to do that if agreed so the
party could just wave and say or the
attorney could for them could say that
they didn't want to do
that wasn't that if I could uh I I hear
what you're saying um there is no fiscal
note and so I'm
wondering if there is a
guarantee of legal
counsel
um that is included in this um or is it
possible that
someone would be involved in
um uh I mean it it is you know it
is I guess it's criminal because it's
prosecutor or defense
counsel but um so that I believe there
has to be
um Council provided but why isn't there
a fiscal note then
well you know what I I I mean I don't
know for sure but it may it may be that
there that there these proceedings are
conducted already and there and so it
may be that you know this changes the
procedures but but not the not the but
not the whether it will have no effect
on cost I'm not sure I mean but but
maybe not not a substantial amount um so
um any yes repres
stap I hate to dive in on this
but shall be
guilty um it's kind of retive and going
to the next line subject to the
punishment um what about subject to due
process I just have I just have a
problem with the the word guilty in
there I know where it's coming from it's
a message that you could be subject to
the rsa's pointed to two in the first
part but um a declaration of guilty in
the law just doesn't seem appropriate
I'm sorry you know can I can you tell me
I'm I'm not sure where you are which
part which Lang what language are you
referring
to we're on 327 right 34 no we're on 314
we're on 314 314 oh well okay sorry
I'm I'm in a wrong Pew here all right no
no problem any other thank you any other
comments any other comments on
314 all right then I'd ask the clerk to
uh please call the role Vice chairman
Wallace yes rep Alexander yes rep
Andrews rep testerman yes rep Stapleton
yes rep trip yes rep gon yes clerk kab
votes yes rep Perez yes rep Smith yes
rep Horgan yes
rep dorenzo yes yes rep Kenny yes rep
Cary yes rep Jack yes rep
lonza yes rep Manos yes rep CH yes rep
Ming yes chairman Lynn yes motion passes
to1 um Can this go on consent anybody
object to
consent all right consent and uh
representative
uh katab can I ask you to write the
report
sure then lastly we're going to turn to
Senate Bill 327 and the chair recognizes
um uh representative Kenny thank you Mr
chairman I would move Amendment
1449 is there a
second I'll second it right uh hang on
move any second
Perez
all right representative Kennedy you
wish to speak to your Amendment uh yes
please um so it's a very simple
Amendment um in the original bill it
changes lines 18 through 23 um based off
attorney studid dolos testimony um he
has been a sports official uh longer
than I've been alive so he has a lot of
experience with this um two things he
felt missing in the bill um that would
be relevant it's on the amendment it's
on line five uh stalking and criminal
mischief um so this amendment just
simply adds that language
in all right any
uh it does it does see make sense to me
any other comments on this all right
then so um I would propose to just have
a show of hands on the amendment uh all
those in favor of the amendment please
raise your
hand um any opposed all right so that's
that
passes iev stated under the wrong Bill
okay
um shall be guilty of the effect
um all right so I'm sorry so you you
were Oppo you voted no then all right so
um all right so then um we have um I I
guess 19 to one is that correct or
representative Andrew were you are right
with the
amendment oh she was okay all right um
all right so
on TPA o TP and representative uh chair
recognizes representative Kenny who is
desirous of writing the report on this
matter to move OT right do you have oh
no no I understand do he have a motion
I'll move otpa all right is there a
second seconded by representative
Perez uh all right any further
discussion on uh on the bill
uh all right um then our uh I would ask
the clerk to call the
role Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander rep Andrews rep testerman yes
rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep gon
yes cler kab votes yes rep
Perez rep
Smith rep poran yes rep D Lorenzo
yes rep Kenny yes rep Carrie yes rep
Jack yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes
repur yes rep Ming yes chairman Lynn yes
motion passes
22 Mr chair yeah yes um I'm wondering if
at some point we might actually be able
to see our way clear to have a bill that
protects um members of the legislature
from um egregious comments made by um or
threats made by our colleagues wouldn't
that be a good idea thank
you you know can this um uh can this
anyone have object to this going on
consent n all right so it'll be on
consent and representative Kenny so um
those who are writing reports I have
this little note
yes the speaker would like reports in
today if possible um the bottom says so
uh can you can you both get me and I
will get I will get my very
non-technical short report in by the end
of the day today on
4:35
um uh so you know what um just before we
we recess just to let everybody know we
only have one other bill that we've
received from the Senate uh that we
haven't had had a hearing on um I would
prop and we and we need to exact the two
bills that we did have hearings on today
I would propose that we not have a
session next Wednesday for just that um
that know another bill yeah we might I
think we're probably we're GNA I think
we're probably going to get at least
maybe one and maybe two other bills for
some reason we're we're pretty light uh
on Senate bills um so I think we'll have
plenty of time to you know hear those
bills and execute and uh so the earliest
you would plan for us to Mee the
earliest would be right would be two
weeks from today two weeks from today
okay just a note I'll be away that week
that's April vacation week ah okay all
right um all right so uh we'll I mean
we'll yeah we'll we'll miss you but uh
you know we'll you can uh send us a text
from well you know if I I guess what I
would say is this I I we we certainly
won't have a meeting before the 24th but
just on once I once I know we have all
the Senate bills that we're going to get
if it looks like it's not going to be
any heavy lifing at all maybe we can put
it off until the week after that even I
mean that's you know I don't have any
problem with that if we can do
it yeah but U we subtit oh yeah for sure
thank you very much for being here
really appreciate it and for your
questions too I mean that was your
excellent questions uh really appreciate
it all right um any any other business I
guess we're adjourned thank you
everyone